(band stops playing)
(audience cheers)
- Welcome back, I'm here, with
Cedric the Entertainer and
Pam Grier and also Veda Tunstall
from the documentary "Descending", here.
And one of the producers
with her, Quest Love,
dialed in from New York.
And joining us now from Atlanta
is the youngest daughter
of Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
She's an attorney and activist
and author and the CEO of the King Center.
She's got a lot of jobs.
Let's say hi to Dr. Bernice King, y'all.
(audience cheering)
- Hello.
- Hello. Say hello to everyone.
- Hello, everybody. Good to be here.
- Oh my gosh.
- It's a,
- What's up!
- He's like, "I got a shout out."
It's so lovely to have you
here. We were just talking
about Questlove's new
documentary, "Descendant".
Your father frequently connected the past
to the present in his speeches.
So what do you think his
purpose in doing that was?
- I think it was a few things.
One, it was an effort, one, to help
inform the present to help
guide us in the present and future.
And also to help us to correct some things
in the present and in the future.
And help people to understand that
everybody's history is different.
And oftentimes we make assumptions.
And if we don't understand the history
and that's the good, the bad, indifferent
we will bring certain
beliefs to a situation.
And so to dispel a lot of
things, myths, some half truths
he found it necessary to
really give the global context
of the, of the experience
of African Americans,
in particular in this nation.
And also to help the people who were
in that movement understand
that this may have
been the circumstance that we were brought
to this nation, under
this depersonalization.
But we are in a movement
now where I'm gonna help to
boost your personalization,
help you to understand
that you are somebody,
you often reminded us
that in spite of what
happened, we are somebody.
And that boosted them around strength
(audience cheering)
and the hope of the faith
that they needed, in spite of injustices
that we were faced with.
- Absolutely. Well, you were so young
When your father passed. What
memories do you have of him?
- Yeah, you know, I tell
people, unfortunately,
I only have one but it's
a special one because
it's the only one that I
shared with him, that none of
the other siblings shared.
And that was a little game
that we played when he would
come home and I would run up
into his arms and he said,
"We're gonna play the kissing
game today." And essentially
what that was is each one
of us had a spot on his face.
My brother's on either
side of the cheek, I was
on the forehead, my sister was
off to the side of the mouth.
And my mom, of course, smacked
bed in the middle there.
And he would say, "Okay, where is"
and he would just call everybody's name.
My nickname was Bunny,
like the bunny rabbit,
"Where's Bunny kissing
me?", I would hit him there.
And he actually would call
them sugar spots, you know
in the black community we
called them, "gimme some sugar".
So I gave him some sugar
on each one of those spots,
he called each person's name.
And that was our little bonding experience
because when I was born, he
started traveling even more.
And so he wasn't as home as much.
And I think he felt that he
needed to do something special,
so that I would have
that connection with him
because my father always had
a sense that he was not gonna
live a long life and so
he wanted to make sure
that there were meaningful
moments with each one of us.
- Well, that's a beautiful memory.
(audience cheering)
We wanna hear how you're being
of service this Martin Luther
King Jr Day, everybody.
So tell us on Instagram, just tag the show
and we will be right back
with "What I'm Liking",
other than this episode.